hey guys and welcome back to the channel
this is going to be a long one so grab
some popcorn get a blanket and sit down
let's get ready for the ride I am going
to be doing the same cuz as you all know
I hate to actually edit my footage so
I'm going to try and onake this which
means it is going to take me an absolute
while so a couple of quick announcements
uh first off thank you to Ricardo uh one
of my viewers who has at least partially
accredited me with helping him get some
awesome staff offers uh he's going to
end up at Stripes so congrats to you
dude Janu amazing job and uh to all the
viewers who he uh has basically helped
get over here uh via his Reddit post
welcome to the channel hopefully you'll
enjoy this uh so today we're going to be
covering Uber so as I often do uh when
covering a video I do my best to
actually go ahead and look up a bunch of
content about it beforehand um you know
just random blog posts as well as other
YouTube videos even though I've made
this one before I mostly just reference
what I've done in the past cuz I don't
want to redo work but uh you know I
always try to check if I missed
something so I found some video on
making Uber that covers it in 16 minutes
and it has 600,000 views and I'm sitting
here thinking to myself wow I'm about to
cover probably like 5% of uber in an
hour if I'm lucky and uh yeah wow I get
why Ricardo is saying this goes a little
bit more in depth than other channels
anyways guys let's go ahead and get into
it I want to go to bed soon enough so uh
don't want to take too long here I'm
going to do my best all righty let's go
ahead and get into this thing
so for those of you who are not familiar
maybe you don't have Uber in your
country though I do think it is pretty
Global at this point Uber is pretty
simple I want a car I get a car it takes
me to where I want to go so for example
if Kate Upton were to come to me and
tell me to come over I ask her why that
actually is she says just do it I have a
surprise for you obviously I'm going to
come over there who knows what the
surprise is but there's not any chance
in the world that I'm going to say no so
obviously I'm off to Kate Upton's house
and Uber is going to show me where I am
on the map where she is on the map it's
going to show me the the route to get
there it's going to show me the nearby
cars in my area and then it is going to
help me match with the driver in order
to take me there so for those of you who
have been around on this channel long
enough to have seen my Uber 1.0 video
you'll know that I actually covered
Google Maps in this video as well I
bunched them together I'm actually not
going to do this this time around the
reason being that I want to go into a
lot more depth in these 2.0 series and
uh if I'm going to do that it means that
probably Google Maps deserves its own 30
minutes at least
and uh so does Uber so in this
particular video I am going to be
attempting to cover the following one is
going to be literally just requesting a
ride how do we see drivers near us how
do we actually match with them so that
is going to be Point number two uh Point
number three is that we want to be able
to provide some amount of distance that
we are away from our uh location that we
want to go to and also the amount of
time that the ride will take so the
thing with number three is this is
pretty much all provided by some sort of
mapping service and like I mentioned I
want to make a a dedicated video to this
so I will do that in a couple of weeks
um I'm not going to cover this directly
right now for now let's assume that we
can abstract this all the way into some
third party service which I'll call
Google Maps and then eventually we'll
talk about how we would actually go
ahead and make that and then number four
is we have to actually compute the exact
route that we are taking as we're taking
it uh this is good in terms of analytics
purposes for Uber it's good in terms of
you know giving GPS instructions for
What Turn a driver should take it's good
in terms of knowing how much the ride
actually costs as opposed to just
estimations uh this is an important
thing and it's not so easy actually
because the GPS signal coming from your
phone is not perfectly precise it might
be unclear which road you're actually on
so this is actually going to get
complicated I'm not sure if someone in
an actual interview will ask you about
part four of this question but I
actually think it's a very cool
extension this problem and uh I
definitely do think it is a hard problem
as well so let's start moving on I'm
going to do some extremely crude
capacity estimates here uh which again
like I'm not aiming to be that accurate
my whole idea here is I just want to get
the order of magnitude right I might not
even be correct on the order of
magnitude I might be a couple off but I
hope at least that these calculations
will give us an estimate of you know
whether we need to do things like
partitioning or replication or anything
like that so let's imagine that everyone
in the world is using Uber and that
everyone in the world is taking one
20-minute ride per week so if a ride is
20 minutes that means there are around
500 ride slots per week right like if
I'm a driver and I'm working all 24
hours of the week I can service around
500 rides if each one takes about 20
minutes so if there are about 10 billion
people in the world if there are 500
slots that a person could you know take
per week in their Uber ride that means
that there are going to be on average
around 20 million rides at a time now
again I mentioned these calculations are
going to be very crude I think you can
get away with this in an interview but
you know you can refine these if you
want so again if we want to be able to
say if I'm a a Rider and I'm a driver
and I want to map all the locations uh
in our service we have to keep track of
where everyone is there are going to be
40 million people at a time to map right
the 20 million Riders and if we're
assuming a one:1 ratio of riders to
drivers then also another 20 million
drivers so let's imagine now that you
know we're mapping people by their
latitude their longitude and each one of
those can be mapped with a 64 uh bit
long I wrote bytes here but it actually
meant bits so it's really eight bytes
sorry
bits and bits and then also that 64-bit
ID okay so if we multiply those all
together it comes out to around a
gigabyte of storage which is actually
not a lot at all if we want to just go
ahead and store the locations of all the
people that are active in our system
however we do actually have a problem
here which is that uh we're going to be
constantly updating these locations
right from the second I request a ride
and from the second that I'm actually in
a ride I basically am constantly telling
the servers where it is that I'm I'm
going and so even if the storage itself
is not a lot there's going to be a ton
of network requests being made and if
I'm just thinking about the number of
ride requests being made right not even
the number of location updates if I'm
assuming that there are 20 million ride
requests per 20 minutes that means that
equates to around 15,000 requests per
second you can do the math there and
that is going to be a lot right most
servers are not going to be able to
handle 15,000 requests per second we're
going to need to do some amount of
partitioning just to handle all of that
network data
cool so we've gotten that out of the way
and now we can start touching upon the
first part of the problem which is going
to be actually finding a ride so I hate
to say this to you guys if this is the
first time watching my channel but there
is actually a couple of prerequisites to
this video the main one being the Yelp
video that I just did last week so in
that Yelp video I described the process
of running a database query to find all
points near you right so if I'm at a
certain point in a map and I basically
want to find all the points that are
nearby me I need a special type of
database index to do so using a normal
index you know which could be indexed
first on our exp position and then
within an X position would be indexed on
our y position is not very efficient
right because I can say hey all right
you know if my point is here that I'm
looking for and I want to find
everything within this radius well first
I have to go find everything within this
x radius which I can do and then because
uh you can only sort on one field at a
time and then do inner sorts for every X
in index I now do know exactly uh you
know where the Y points are that I want
to get however that doesn't really help
me because now as opposed to being able
to have all of these points that I want
collocated within the database they can
actually be spread out all over the
place right so you know I could have x y
and maybe I want these three points but
then these guys are garbage and then
these guys are good and then these guys
are garbage and ideally for range
queries we want good data locality on
disk otherwise the whole thing is going
to be slow and so just a normal index is
not going to work as well for us again I
recommend that you watch the uh Geo
indexing video that I've posted if
you're more curious about this but
hopefully that explanation was decent
enough the other option of course as I
alluded to is using a geospatial index
so in a geospatial index we basically
take our 2D plane and we break it down
into a bunch of different bounding boxes
so in fact we actually have bounding
boxes so this bounding box would be the
a box and then we have bounding boxes so
as you can see I could now break this
bounding box into four pieces and then
this would be the AA box the ab box the
AC box and the ad box and we could even
break those into tinier pieces right
this would be ACA AC B AC a c d and so
basically by breaking down our 2D plane
into a bunch of different bounding boxes
we can actually just search within a box
in order to find all the points that are
relevant to us right so if I'm looking
to find all the points near this guy
here as you can see the majority of them
are going to lie within box BC I know
that you know if I'm at the top right of
box BC that a couple of the points could
lie in box ba maybe even possible that
some of them would lie in box BD and
then so I can search for all of those
but the main thing with a geospatial
index that makes it so useful is that
when I actually lay out all of the
geospatial hashes right so all of these
points have a hash right so let's
imagine this target point right here is
something like I don't know b c d a b
keep in mind that I'm now laying out a
bunch of other points on disk and so all
of the points that are close to me in 2D
coordinate space are going to be
directly next to me on disk and so again
we achieve that data locality that we
care about we can do a binary search uh
around this area and as a result we can
quickly find all the points that are
close great hopefully that makes sense
so that's step one of finding a ride is
literally understanding how a GEOS
spatial index Works step two is that we
need to keep it updated right if I am at
a certain point in our geospatial index
every couple of seconds I'm moving
around if I'm a driver and if I'm a
writer I could be even moving around a
little bit as well and so we have to
send updates to that index to actually
tell them where we now are so of course
we could send these via a normal HTTP
request right and make a post to our
server however there is one slight issue
with that which is that HTTP requests
require sending headers and if we're
going to do this thing every couple of
seconds anyway it would be great if we
just didn't have to send those so what
technology could help us out here is
something known as websockets websockets
are a real-time bidirectional connection
between the server and the
client and of course this is going to be
very useful for us because in addition
to actually sending out our updates to
the server we can now actually see where
other drivers on that same server are
located cool so hopefully that makes
sense so step three is again like I
mentioned before during the capacity
estimate stage even though our index
doesn't actually get a ton of data it is
going to get a ton of different requests
from all the users and drivers that are
updating their locations so we're going
to probably have to partition this thing
out to make sure that every single
partition gets an even amount of load in
terms of the number of requests being
made and so if you watch my Yelp video
you'll recall that of course when it
comes to geolocation data we have to be
smart right because geolocation load is
not spread out evenly in major cities
such as New York City over here there's
going to be a lot more load per square
foot than there is in something like
Middle America oops accidental erase so
again we have to be smart about the way
that we partition our data in addition
we also need it to be the case that all
locations that are close by to one
another are on the same partition right
if I'm a rider I want it to be the case
that all drivers that are close to me
are on my my partition because otherwise
if I wanted to search for all close
driver I would have to hit a bunch of
different partitions and that would be
bad so again basically the idea here is
that we want similar locations to have
similar geohashes we're already doing
this as a result of our geospatial index
and they should be on the same node and
of course this basically just means that
we want to be doing partitioning by our
geohash range but in a way that actually
balances them so that all of the
partitions get similar amounts of load
so we discussed how we could actually do
that a bit in the Yelp video i' would
recommend uh looking at that but
basically it does unfortunately involve
a lot of tinkering there are a lot of
third party services that can help you
do this uh but yeah it's certainly not
an easy process and you know is a video
within itself so let's actually go ahead
and continue talking about this
partitioning right so again even if
there are some partitions that cover
really small amounts of area they can
still get too much load right if uh I'm
in Time Square which is a part of New
York City on New Year's Eve which is
where the ball drops so it's super duper
crowded what you're going to see is tons
and tons of people requesting Uber is
home you know let's say right after
midnight right everyone uh lets the ball
drop they're all tired they want to go
home I personally stay out till 5:00
a.m. like a beast uh but others you know
they do their own thing so for these
situations what you can actually have is
within a particular geographic area you
can even do a secondary Shard on that
and you can just Shard based on user ID
right so even though all of these guys
correspond to that area for Time Square
this is like user ID a through e and
this is user ID e through
I don't know what's 2/3 through the
alphabet P and then uh Q through Z I
don't know English evidently anyways the
point is even though I said this was
kind of the the range this should be the
range on the hash of the username so
that they are distributed equally
anyways the idea is of course to First
route the request by the geohash and
then from there if there are multiple
different uh leader nodes that this
request can go to you would then look at
the user ID and perform an additional
round of hashing to figure out where the
request is actually going to go and this
is definitely something that Uber
actually does when I was doing research
it turns out that uh particularly by the
San Francisco Airport of all places
there is tons of traffic and as a result
they have multiple different replicas uh
basically allowing you to match with
drivers which is pretty cool so step
four after we've done all of this is
that as we move from one area to another
this is especially relevant for drivers
they're actually going to have to change
which partition they're connecting to
and if you recall what we were
previously connected to our last
partition with was a websocket and
that's a little bit problematic because
that is a p a persistent connection so
recall the idea here is you know we've
got some load balancer right that's
going to say if I send you my location
you're going to have to connect me to a
given server that is going to show where
my location is and so first I'm going to
do that obviously because that is going
to tell me like hey you know if Step One
is go to the load balancer the load
balancer is going to say step two is
connect to Partition one because that is
where you're currently located however
if I then send another message right and
I establish my websocket so I now tell
partition one I'm actually over in
Partition two what partition one needs
to do is break this connection because
then our client can go ahead and say
shoot I don't have a connection anymore
I need to go back to the load balancer
so it's now for step three going to go
back to the load balancer the load
balancer is going to say hey wait a
second you're actually in Partition 2
now and now all of a sudden you're
making a webite with this guy you don't
have this guy anymore so the one thing
to note there is we do want to be
careful of the Thundering Herd problem
namely you know when you are
reconnecting via websocket uh you don't
want a ton of different nodes
reconnecting to this guy P2 at once but
it probably won't happen because it's
not like everyone is leaving partition
one at once and going into partition two
okay now let's actually go ahead and
talk about finding a ride so the first
thing is this we want the reads and wrs
of the writer and the driver location to
be as fast as possible the reason being
that they're happening every few seconds
we don't want them to themselves take a
couple of seconds or else we would be
overloading our servers another thing to
note is we don't really care if data is
persistent right if I'm a rider and you
know my location is in some sort of
server uh you know if for whatever
reason that server goes down or it gets
lost for something it gets deleted it's
not a huge deal because I'm actually
about to upload my information to the
server in another 3 seconds I don't
really care about data persistence I
care about data speed and low latency so
ideally we would keep our whole
partitioned geolocation index on our
servers in memory in fact because that's
going to make things even faster if we
you know neglect to use a database here
which is what I'm saying we ought to do
not only do we not have to make an extra
Network call so it's you know just
client right to server right there's no
there's no uh database over
here terrible drawing don't have any of
this and also if we're just keeping
everything in memory because there's not
a lot of things to store like I
mentioned it's only like a gigabyte to
store it so we can easily keep it in
memory uh in a pretty inexpensive manner
so let's just go ahead and do that okay
number two is that if a node goes down
we can basically just assign a standby
node to its partition so I'm proposing
that you know we've got a few unused
servers right here so for whatever
reason this guy goes goes down it's
communicating with some sort of
Zookeeper instance uh which in reality
you know is distributed consensus so
there's three nodes over here they're
all talking to one another uh
two and
three and then eventually they decide
amongst the three of them that this guy
is in fact down and now they can say oh
wait but this guy is up let's go ahead
and actually promote
him so now all of a sudden this standby
node is going to take the partition of
the Dead node and now our client is
communicating with that guy so keep in
mind though that if this guy goes down
and if this guy gets promoted now we
have a bunch of clients who are starting
to uh try to establish websocket
connections with it which could turn
into a Thundering Herd so the way that
you would stop that right of all the
clients right because if I have this guy
over here and this guy over here they're
also going to attempt to establish web
hooks at the same time or rather web
sockets and the way that we can stop
this is just by saying well you know if
this guy goes down you wait 10 seconds
you wait five seconds you wait three
seconds and that's going to distribute
things a little
bit cool so now let's actually talk
about picking a driver so the first
thing to note is there are a variety of
different charistics that you can use to
pick a driver um you know I'm not going
to like enforce for the sake of the
interview that you use one of them uh
but I think it's worth noting that there
are different options so first is
closest right you literally go in your
geolocation index and you pick the guy
that's closest to you that's pretty easy
uh number two is you send it to everyone
and the first person to respond saying
yes I accept this ride is going to win
uh the next one is the highest rating
wins uh this obviously would of course
require us having a driver's actual
review score in the Geo index itself so
now we have to store a little bit more
data so there's a slight downside there
but it's not a huge deal uh but also
another downside of this one is that you
actually have to fetch everyone who's
relatively close and then sort them by
their review score so that's a little
bit of extra latency when actually
requesting a ride um so there are a few
different approaches of actually doing
this but all of them uh have in common
that there are race conditions possible
right because even if you do pick the
closest guy the closest guy can still
reject your offer uh and so we do have
to have the ability to you know go and
send to the second
closest and so whenever you have
something like this where you know you
provide an opportunity to One driver and
then if that doesn't work out you
provide an opportunity to another driver
there are plenty of opportunities for
race conditions so let's see how that
might happen well number one is the
server looks for the closest driver
right so it finds one it's this guy over
here and it says Hey do you accept this
ride now what's going to happen is he
actually does accept the ride however it
takes 5 seconds for that Network request
to get back to the server right uh the
response is unbounded in terms of how
much time it can take and as a result we
never know when the response is coming
in so as a result the server 5 seconds
later says you know what it doesn't seem
like this guy has responded let me go
and send it to this guy number two now
he's going to accept right as the third
thing that happens and so this is
actually going to get back to the server
before number four and so now driver
number two thinks he has
ride blah blah
blah so the driver number two now thinks
he has the ride uh he's been told by the
database hey actually no one else has
claimed this yet you're good to go and
then all of a sudden this guy comes back
in claims the ride and now they both
think they have the ride and that would
be very very bad so in order to actually
conclusively make sure that no one uh
ever thinks they have the ride at
another time we need some sort of
locking mechanism right so imagine we
have some database table called claimed
trips where you know a trip first starts
out as an unclaimed trip and then uh it
becomes a claim trip when a driver gets
assigned to it basically this is when a
riter asks the server for a driver and
so the first thing that the server does
is assign an ID for that trip and it
doesn't have to put it in a database yet
it can do anything with it but now the
server has basically a couple of options
the first is it can actually materialize
a conflict in the database what does
this mean well uh effectively it means
you add a row to the database uh with an
unclaimed trip so no driver assigned but
it has the proper trip ID so again null
driver but has the trip ID and the
reason this is going to help us out is
because now there's actually a row for
us to lock on when claiming that trip so
that the drivers don't actually think
that they both have it if there wasn't a
row there it's possible that both of
those drivers would just add the row and
if the row doesn't exist we can't really
lock on it can we unless of course we
were to use something called predicate
locks where predicate locks are
effectively uh you know it allows you to
uh lock on rows that don't even actually
exist yet by using something known as a
predicate which which is effectively
just a SQL query itself right so you
could say lock all rows with a given
trip ID uh of course this is going to be
slow unless our table is indexed by trip
ID because like I mentioned the
predicate lock is itself a query and so
we'd have to scan through the whole
table of trip
IDs um and that's going to be pretty
slow that's linear time and that's bad
if there are a lot of trips but of
course if this guy is actually indexed
and sorted that sort time or rather the
the query time becomes o of log n where
n is the number of rows in the table we
can quickly find our trip ID and then
we're good to go so that is a solid
option now of course these are all
techniques the database is use in order
to ensure uh full serializability of
course we could also just use a database
that supports transactions which is what
I personally would opt to do I think
using something like a mySQL database
which is just you know sharded and
partitioned or not sharded and
partitioned but sharded and indexed on
trip ID itself is going to be sufficient
here right because again we can easily
perform that predicate locking or
materialize the conflict easy enough uh
if we're using transactions we don't
have to worry about any of this and uh
everyone is familiar enough with my
sequel we're not going to be creating
that many of these rows at a time such
that you know writing or reading is
probably going to be a bottleneck here I
think my sequel is probably good
enough Okay so we've just finished the
first part of the video so that part of
the video is probably what I would say
that
90% of uber systems design interviews
are going to be concerned about right
you know creating that geolocation index
uh matching the driver and I guess I've
kind of brushed past it partially just
because the geolocation index itself is
something that we talked about so much
in Yelp now we have the Super Ultra
Balls to the walls incredibly hard part
of the problem which I will dub route
Recreation so this is one that's going
to take a bit you don't have to watch it
but if you do watch it I promise it's
pretty cool anyways we're 23 minutes in
let's keep going so the idea here is
that when we get a GPS signal from a
phone it's not perfect right so if I
have two points on a road we've got
point a and point B I might get a GPS
signal that's actually kind of right in
between them and now I don't know where
my car is so the issue with that is that
you know we want to know our exact root
so what can we do to rectify this well
we can actually use some probabilistic
models so if I have this signal I know
for a fact that it's pretty unlikely
that I'm at Point C and it's also pretty
unlikely that I'm at Point D because
they're pretty far away additionally if
I first had a signal here and then I had
one here I know it's probably more
likely that I'm at point B than point a
because this guy is you know over here
on the road that leads to point B so
this is kind of the general idea that
we're going to be getting into we're
going to be building ourselves a nice
hidden marov model and we'll get all
into that so the first concept that I'm
going to be talking about is called
emission probabilities and the idea here
is basically you know if I'm at a given
location on the road what is the
distribution of GPS signals that might
come from my you know from my phone
right if I'm actually here over on point
a you know maybe it's very likely that I
get signals over here and it's less
likely that I get signals over
here and it's not at all likely that I
get signals over here so we can actually
model this with a math equation which is
what Uber does I think they use the
reverse ha sign distance or something
like that I'm no mathematician Google it
yourself uh but the the idea is an
emission property is basically saying
you know if I were to see a certain
point uh what's the likelihood that my
phone was actually over at Point a cool
so hopefully that makes sense you should
notice that you know if I were at b
instead there would be a different
distribution of points that would be
likely I'd be really likely to see a GPS
signal from here less likely to see one
from here even less likely to see one
from here and I'm definitely not seeing
one from here notice however that as we
covered in the last example that kind of
radius of GPS signals that we might see
could be shared in common for two
different points and that of course is
when things are going to get a bit
confusing so the next thing that we're
going to be talking about is something I
already mentioned a little bit known as
transition probabilities so this is
basically saying you know if I'm at one
point on the road what's the probability
that the next place my car is going to
be at is on this other point of the road
right so from point A over here maybe I
have a model that tells me oh you know
what because this guy is's a highway I'm
really likely to stay on the highway and
be at Point e next I'm a little bit less
likely to get off the highway and go to
point C there's only a 30% shot of that
and just because Point D is all the way
over here and point B is all the way on
the other side of the highway there's a
0% chance that I can go from a over to
one of those guys so we can actually
model these percentages uh by basically
using historic data by basically you
know using certain charistics like
Highway are more likely than like
getting off a highway things like that
and so now all of a sudden what we've
done is built out this cool probability
model so let's go ahead and bring it
together imagine I saw 0.1 and 2 so 0.1
is over here Point 2 is over here
between those radiuses of Point C and
point e and so if I were to see that
sequence 01 and0 2 what are the two
points on the road that I was most
likely at well for starters for point
one we're pretty confident that we came
from a right because it's actually the
only point you know if I model B's
distribution like this and D's like this
it's really the only point on the road
uh where point one is in its Circle so
I'm pretty confident I came from a right
and if I know I came from a then let's
look at Point 2 so0 2 might actually be
a little bit closer to point C then
point e but even if it is it probably
doesn't matter the reason being that if
we're already at Point a it's so much
more likely that we end up at Point e
than Point C that the higher probability
of being offset by Point C is basic
rather the the higher probability of
being emitted from point C is actually
offset by the higher transition
probability of going to point e so
hopefully that intuition makes a little
bit of sense there right like we're not
just looking at this point point 2 the
GPS signal compared to other points on
the road but we're also looking at the
trail of points that we we've seen
because the chain of them is actually
going to tell us more information about
where we actually are so this is all you
know beian probability and it is
encapsulated by a hidden marov model so
again if this gets a little bit too
mathy for you I don't blame you it's not
my cup of tea either but for those of
you who do enjoy the math I'll devote
one slide to it and then hopefully we
can go talk about algorithms from there
so let's imagine we modeled emission
probabilities as this right so it's the
probability that if I see a GPS
signal basically it's it's the
probability that I see a GPS signal
given I'm on a certain point in a road
right so that's the emission uh GPS
signal uh one
given I am at Point
a so the transition probability is a
little bit different it's
saying you know I'm at Pro basically
probability I am at Road
given I was
at Road
one hopefully that notation makes a
little bit of sense so far so if I were
to see the signals
gps1 then gps2 right so imagine I'm
seeing 0.1 and 0 2 that's what I'm
modeling here what's the probability of
that really it's very simple all it is
is the probability that we see the
signal gps1 given we're on road one
times the probability that we are at
Road two given we were at Road one right
so imagine this here it's the
probability that we see 0.1 given we're
at a times the probability that we're at
e given we were at a and then also times
the probability that we see2 two given
we're at
e so hopefully that's simple enough now
you might be saying to yourself well
that alone isn't enough to know that uh
it is the most likely sequence we
actually have to do that for all
possible sequences of roads and then
take the highest one right so take
Max so for me to really be confident
that I actually had the most likely
sequence of roads I would have to try
this for you know a a a a c um a e a d
and on and on and on and on and on even
though these guys have zero probability
for emission if we really want to be uh
sure that we haven't seen everything we
still have to try them
right so the issue now is if we have X
GPS signals that are emitted and we have
y different points on the road there are
going to be y to the X combinations that
we have to consider now if you remember
your lead code anything that is
exponential time complexity is a real
no-go it is going to take forever to
compute and yeah ultimately just far too
slow for us so the question is how can
we actually go ahead and make this
process faster well for those of you who
are still angry at lead code I have a
dynamic programming problem for you and
it is known as the vby algorithm so the
vby algorithm is actually a way of uh
you know figuring out the answer to the
most likely sequence given a hidden
marov model and as opposed to running in
exponential time it is actually running
in quadratic time relative to the number
of roads in this case and then linear
relative to the number of signals so
this is a gigantic Improvement in terms
of you know the speed that we're running
this thing so let's actually go ahead
and explain how it would work so
basically the idea is this for our first
signal let's keep going and thinking
about that uh you know example that we
were using just a couple of slides ago
for a first signal we want to find the
probability it is emitted by each road
so we just have our emission probability
we're not thinking about transitions yet
and then for the second signal and on we
basically use the previous results right
we take the highest possible path from
each node and then we use it to
calculate the most likely path ending at
each node so we go from each node we
have a probability there already and
then we use it to calculate the next set
of probabilities for the next Signal
Point so I'm going to do my best to
illustrate this I'm not the best teacher
but uh let's see what I can do so let's
imagine now that basically you know
signal one comes in forget what the
emission probabilities are there don't
worry about it and then signal 2 comes
in and so I say that you know through
signal 2 I see that if my car was at
Point a and then it was at Point a again
I would have a 1/4 probability of seeing
the GPS signals that I've seen
if I have to look at all potential roots
that end in a I would now have to say
okay you know if my car was actually at
a and then it was actually at B I would
have a 1/2 possibility of um you know
basically the there's a one half chance
that I would see these signals right so
now the question is what do I do for
Signal 3 so another signal comes in and
so the question is you know uh basically
was I at um a a a a a
b a b
a or a b b the reason I say that is
because in the vby algorithm we actually
only care about these points from our
signal 2 and then we go and do another
Crossing between these guys where keep
in mind the crossing is basically you
know we take these possible signals we
multiply them all by their transition
and their emission probabilities and
then at every single node you just take
the max possible
number so let's see to simplify things a
little
bit in this case it would really be the
max of AA times
transition from A to
B and this guy would be the max or
rather just
a times
transition from B to
B and the idea here is that you know
only these calculations alone are going
to tell us uh the max possible path
ending at B on the third signal and so
you might ask
yourself why is it basically that uh we
can discount any of the other paths thus
far why is it that BBB can't have the
highest probability
well basically keep in mind that at
every single step we're really just you
know taking the highest thing up to that
point and then we're multiplying by the
transition probabilities regardless and
so if we're multiplying by the
transition probability from here to here
if I know that
BB was less than AB before I know that
sorry I'm running out of space here BB
times the transition
probability is less than AB times the
transition
probability and so as a result again we
have found our dynamic programming use
we basically just need to memorize the
calculation of the previous signal and
then we're good to go if I didn't
explain this well I apologize there's
really one takeaway to get which is this
as opposed to the naive algorithm of
hidden marov models which in theory
could be run in parallel right you just
do this calculation for all combin of
roads in parallel in the verby algorithm
we need to run this thing sequentially
in order for me to calculate the best
result for Signal number three I need to
know the result for Signal number
two so again the point here is that this
thing is stateful we need to run it
sequentially for Signal X I need to know
the probabilities for Signal
X-1 and so again this is going to make
our life a whole lot tougher right
because if we have to do all this
computation it's a little bit
complicated it now means that as I send
points coming in those points have to be
able to access the state of the previous
node in order to do the next
calculation so the good thing for us is
that this state isn't too big so I did
mention that in a vby algorithm in most
hidden marov models you would have to
consider every possible path or at least
you know all possible paths ending at
one particular layer of nodes however
for the majority of these you know roads
uh a lot of the paths are just going to
have a zero probability right because
some of the emission signals are going
to be so far away from certain points at
a road that we can actually just
discount that whole node and then not
even worry about it so at least in my
opinion I think the state itself that we
have to pass around from calculation to
calculation will probably be pretty
small so again probably only a few
sequences of roads will actually make
sense and have nonzero
probabilities okay so I've gone through
all this math that's been pretty useless
thus far and now it's actually time to
get into the whole distributed systems
aspect of this thing because this is
where it really gets fun so here's the
first thing we're going to say our
hidden Markov model is Big right there's
a lot of data here we're modeling the
probability that every single road is
potentially going to every single one of
its neighbors and again that just takes
a lot of data to do and so because we
have all of these transition
probabilities now all of a sudden we
probably have to go ahead and make
partitions right so that is going to be
tough so imagine we have the following
scenario our car starts out in zone one
which is going to represent one
partition of our hidden markof model so
P1 is going to hold all of the
transition probabilities there then we
go to S2 so same node we're all good
right we're still accessing the same
data and now all of a sudden we go into
S3 which is now part of a different
partition right this is part of Zone 2
and so all of a sudden a different
server is holding the transition
probabilities that we need so in theory
this wouldn't actually be that
problematic if we could run all of these
calculations in parallel however these
calculations are stateful and I need the
result of this guy right I need the
result of the calculation for S2 in
order to perform the calculation for S3
and so now all of a sudden you know P1
might be holding the state from these
two calculations but now it has to
actually go from P1 to P2 and so the
question is how does it actually get
there so basically there are a couple of
uh points that I'm going to talk about
before we uh talk about how we can pass
this state around over the network the
first is that we want to be partitioning
our hmm like I mentioned and we're going
to do this in a way very similar to our
driver matching service right so the
idea is that we want close uh points
that are actually close to one another
in space on the same partition because
if I'm moving around a little bit it
would be great if all of my queries to
figure out the transition probabilities
from one road to another uh were on the
same Noe and as a result we want to
basically partition our hmm in the same
exact way that we did earlier where you
know New York City gets a node Middle
America gets a node etc etc etc so
there's one slight exception right which
is that imagine I'm moving first from
point A here to point B and A and B are
basically going to be on different
partitions now the issue with that is
that I actually need to know the
transition probability when I see point
B I need to basically know the
transition probability from A to B and
I'm not going to have that if a is on a
different zone right so now this is a
different partition so what we can
actually do is in order to ensure that
all of the transition probabilities that
we need are on our partition that we are
querying we can actually extend our HMF
bounds a little bit so that for example
all of the hmm transition probabilities
held on partition 2 are going to extend
a little bit past the zone 2 boundary
right it should end here but it actually
ends here and we're going to do the same
thing for P1 right so it should end over
here but now it's actually going to end
down here and what this is going to
allow us to do is you know this query
right if I see this GPS signal this is
going to be handled by P1 P1 needs to
know hey what's the likelihood uh of a
to B we can see it's 80% but that would
normally be held over on P2 but if we
just extend these bounds a little bit
now all of a sudden that 80% is also
held on P1 and we can do our calculation
again I'm sorry if this is getting a
little abstract but hopefully the
general idea makes sense here which is
that if I just cross a partition
boundary I need to know the transition
probability across partitions and it
would be bad if we had to go to multiple
nodes in order to figure that
out okay we're still dealing with
partitions here because again this is
all very complicated stuff and uh even
though it feels convoluted this is
actually kind of similar to what Uber
really does who would have thought so
the idea is again we need to access our
last computation right not our last trip
but rather our last
signal so if I have signal two I need to
know the computation from signal one and
so the idea is if we move partitions we
need to be able to fetch that state so
imagine signals 1 through five are all
in P1 all of a sudden signal 6 comes
along that's now located in P2 right
it's just a different zone of the map
now all of a sudden this guy needs the
state from P1 it's got to ask it for it
hey can I have your
state doesn't necessarily have to ask it
for it but there's got to be some sort
of mechanism for actually passing that
state around so here is the way I'm
going to be proposing to do it basically
I propose that when we pass a
signal
like a GPS signal to our partitions like
so it should look something like this it
should contain trip ID it should contain
the previous location that the car was
at before this one so the last signal
and then also our current location so
this is going to allow us to accomplish
a couple of things the first is it also
tells us uh when we're actually starting
and stopping a trip right if the
previous location is null the current
location is not equal null then these
servers know that we're actually
starting a trip which is useful because
now they're going to have to start
keeping track of State before they might
have said oh shoot we should have this
state where is it I might need it trip
started the next is If the previous
location was not null and the current
location is null we can basically say
okay that means the trip is finished
let's take our route that we've
calculated the most likely one we can
upload it to some sort of Trip's
database and the idea here is that also
this signal has all of the information
that we need in order to
deterministically figure out which
partition this is going to right there
should be some sort of load balancer
here and the load balancer using all
three of these
fields is going to be able to figure out
where this message should go it can take
a geohash of our current location if
we're doing some inner sharding again
because you know think about the Time
Square on New Year's example if there
are you know if there's tons of load for
a small given area we may have to do
some inner sharding within that and then
then we could do an inard on our trip ID
as well to figure out which particular
replica our query is being sent to right
so if I have um you know Zone one uh
replica
one and then Zone
one replica
2 I basically need to figure out you
know using the trip ID because I already
know from my uh geohash that I'm going
to Zone one but using the trip ID do I
go here or do I go down here and we want
to keep that consistent of course and
we'll explain that in a little
bit okay well actually you know what
let's explain that now why do we want to
you know keep which node we're hitting
consistent well the reason of course is
that we're maintaining this state from
before and so these guys are going to be
stateful consumers and so if you know
I'm non-deterministically hitting you
know this guy on one signal and then
this guy the state that I need is not
going to be maintained so I actually
need you know like Jordan's
trip half has to be on Zone one replica
1 and if I go to a different Zone then
I'm going to have to take Jordan's trip
and I'm going to have to send it
there okay let's talk about interp
partition communication I thought I was
real clever for this one it's possible
that one of the senior Engineers who
watches my video is going to roast me
and I am open to such a thing so like I
mentioned from before the toughest thing
about this whole problem is that cars
can go from one zone to another and when
they do you have to actually go ahead
head and move the data associated with
that car right so the whole point of the
verby algorithm is that I need the
result of the last computation if the
last computation is being stored on a
stateful consumer for Zone one now all
of a sudden I have to send it to the
stateful consumer for Zone 2 so if you
keep hearing the word stateful consumer
and you've watched enough of my videos
which many of you have you know that I
am a Flink sexual Apache should be
paying me at this point they can't cuz
they're open source and they have no
money but if they could they should be
paying me anyways the point is what am I
proposing as per usual I'm proposing
using Kofa Q's as well as Flink the
reason being that kfka Hughes are
basically a distributed log based broker
so of course all of those messages are
going to be persistent and replayable
and Flink is capable of keeping State
and actually occasionally checkpointing
it to ensure that all of those message
are eventually going to be processed at
least once so how do I actually want to
to go ahead and convey vby State between
uh between signals right so if I switch
from Zone one to zone two now all of a
sudden I have to give the state from my
verby calculations from Zone one to zone
two how do I propose we do this well
basically I'm saying that we should go
ahead and actually send the trip vby
state to the kfka Q for uh for the new
Partition right so we're going to have
Zone one over here we're going to have
Zone Zone 2 over here Zone one is going
to say wait a second I see that the car
is no longer in my partition let's go
ahead and send it to
Kafka and then zone two can go ahead and
consume that we're going to now
illustrate all of this because I have
been so abstract and everyone is better
learning visually so let's go ahead and
do it so the idea here is as follows I'm
going to do my best to explain this so
imagine we have Zone one is this box on
my right zone two is the other box on my
right as I mentioned the actual
partitions themselves for the hidden
marov model nodes the stateful consumers
are going to be a little bit bigger than
that just so that we have all the
transition probabilities that we need so
like I mentioned the data model that I
want to use for sending signals is like
such we've got trip
ID previous
location new
location New location so in this case
the previous location was null the new
location is going to be P1 and the trip
ID is going to be 10 so the tripa is
going to start out in zone one at P1 and
so the first thing that we're going to
do is the client right this is really
all the client that's sending all this
data got my smartphone right here my
smartphone is going to send this guy
over to the load balancer and the load
balancer is going to do the following
they're going to say oh wow the new
location is P1 so let's actually go
ahead and send
this point over to the Zone 1 Q This is
in kfka and this is now going to
initiate holding state for my trip trip
number 10 in the stateful consumer the
next thing that's going to happen is I'm
going to move over to P2 my ride has
gone South a little bit and so now I'm
going to send a message saying hey I was
at P1 before I'm now at P2 my trip ID is
still 10 this goes to the load balancer
the load balancer says oh P2 is still in
zone one which means I'm going to send
you to the Zone 1 Q it's going to take a
goash to figure that out and you know
use our custom partitioning logic and
again this is now going to perform the
Verity calculation right because we have
transition
probabilities for Zone
one so it's going to perform that
calculation and now it's going to update
the state for trip
10 next thing that's going to happen is
now all of a sudden we've actually moved
into zone two and we've gone to point
three
at 3 what's going to happen is we're
still at trip 10 our previous point was
0. 2 now we're at 3 so this is where
things actually get a little bit
interesting when we get to our load
balancer our load balancer is going to
say oh wait a second I see our old point
is in zone one I see our new point is in
zone two I'm actually going to send this
message to both of them so Zone one's
going to get message number three zone
two is going to get Point number three
and so when Zone one sees this it says
oh wait a second
I can see that now all of a sudden
basically this point is no longer in my
zone that I'm responsible for so now I
have to actually take the state for this
trip and send it back to my load
balancer and the load balancer is going
to say oh wait a second well I know
about this because I can see that we're
now currently at. 3 right uh you know
this guy knows that we're at. 3 now and
the load balancer is going to say I'm
going to have to reroute this to
wherever 3 lives which is the zone 2 Q
so now the state from The Zone one Flink
consumer is going to go into the zone 2
Flink
consumer we can establish trip 10
State and then once basically this state
as well as this point have arrived now
three we can now run
vby again I'm sorry if you're not
following along doing my best here but
the idea is you you know we get our
state from the previous calculation we
send it we use our deterministic
partitioning and uh load balancing
algorithm to make sure that it goes to
the right place and now all of the data
that we need is in one place we're
bringing our uh computation to the data
right all of our transition
probabilities live on Zone 2 so we want
to make sure that we're doing this
calculation on Zone 2 and the last thing
that we're going to
do is we're going to move over to P4 the
driver marks our trip is ended so now
all of a sudden sudden we say okay our
old state was P3 our new state is null
the load balancer is going to say oh if
your old state was P3 that means I have
to Route this guy over to Z2 right
because we're in zone two so we're going
to Route uh Point number four over to
zone two and then all of a sudden uh
this guy is going to say oh wait this is
done let's go ahead and send this state
to uh the trips database and now we know
our exact route or at least the most
likely one according to our hidden
Markov
model that was a lot let's go ahead and
outline this thing all at once so we're
going to start off with our client over
here on the left as we do whenever we're
looking for a ride the first thing that
we're going to do is reach out to our
load balancer because all of a sudden we
want to actually say where we are so we
can start looking for nearby drivers so
the first thing that we're going to do
is our load balancer is going to
basically geohash our current location
and match us with one of our nodes and
our matching services so let's say it
matches us with this particular guy
right this one is New York and that's
where I am New
York so we establish a websocket
connection with it and now all of a
sudden we're also consistently getting
data about where the closest drivers are
so we've requested that ride you know a
driver is eventually going to also be
connected to this guy so this is our
driver and when he clicks accept that's
going to go into the trips datab datase
right now all of a sudden our trip has
actually been created both of us know
about it I hear about it through the
websocket he hears about it through just
you know getting a response from the
matching service so also as well through
his websocket and then we can both see
one another's locations again via the
matching Service as he comes to me I get
in his car he clicks hey the ride has
started and now all of a sudden from our
client we're actually sending our
locations during the ride so that we can
calculate the path that we're taking so
this is going to be path
calculation so again as we're actually
sending out all of these GPS signals
right trip
ID old location new location these are
going to go into a load balancer and the
load balancer is going to place uh place
them into basically the correct kfaq
which again we're going to be sharding
on our geohash because we want all of
our hmm nodes to be sharded uh by their
location and balanced properly and if we
have to again think of the new uh the
Time Square on New Year's Eve example or
the San Francisco Airport example we may
have to do some inner sharding on the
actual trip ID itself all of that can be
accounted for deterministically in our
load balancer we can use some sort of
consistent hashing function so again
these guys are all going down over to
our hidden Markov model
nodes which are going to be keeping
state of the last Furby calculation that
we've run and then as a signal comes in
again it's going to run yet another vby
calculation of course if all of a sudden
you know I was going here and now I've
moved my car and I have to start doing
Furby calculations on this node this guy
is going to have to send its state back
to the load balancer which is going to
again route it through the Kafka
que it's really beneficial that all of
these messages are going through Kafka
as a as opposed to using some other sort
of transport protocol because of the
fact that anything that is running
internally Within Flink is guaranteed to
eventually be delivered right so I know
that all my state is going to be uh
checkpointed or snapshotted and I don't
have to worry about nothing getting run
if I were to use just like a direct HTTP
request between these two guys there are
a bunch of race conditions that I could
spend a bunch of time thinking about uh
and dealing with and I would rather not
so I would rather just route them
through Kafka now of course when the
kind of like a finish event comes along
and this guy processes it it's going to
upload that data to the Trip's database
the Trip's database is again like I
mentioned simple mySQL database sharded
on the trip ID and index the same way
you know we can keep it single leader so
we've got this replica and in fact we
also want the data from there to do some
more post-processing on right so we can
extract it via change data capture as
I've done many times before on this
channel throw that bad boy into a Kafka
Q put it into an hdfs sync and then
start running spark jobs the reason for
this is we actually want to just get
more transition
probabilities as we get more data over
time it would be very useful for us to
figure out how likely it is that you go
from one road to another and so we can
actually feed this data into uh
something like a batch processing job
that's going to make those probabilities
more and more accurate and then we can
feed the result of that spark job into
our hidden Markoff model nodes such that
we get more accurate probabilities for
transitions from one road to another
well guys if you have followed along I
am incredibly impressed I don't think I
explained this one particularly well
however I did do my best with some
visualizations I will make sure to
attach an article uh in the description
that I based quite a bit of the latter
part of this video off of uh but again
for those of you who are new to this
channel welcome I'm excited to have you
all here and I'm looking forward to keep
making these videos so have a good night
everyone I will certainly do the same
and I will see you in the next one